this story broke I think was late  yesterday uh-huh was on the radio and  then today it's of course the New York  Times huge revelation about Trump's tax  returns for years this business it's  crazy yeah the New York Times says that  for years like a decade for years  Donald Trump lost the most money of any  American taxpayer yes yeah yeah and then  Trump said did you hear that the most my  Mussolini impression is the same as my  trial that's true they said between 1985  and 1994 Trump lost more than 1 billion  dollars yeah Trump said that was 20  years ago with inflation it's 2 billion  it's very pretty  he's very proud very proud but not  bright yeah did you say this is even a  joke did you see that he said the first  thing he said I believe was something  along the lines of that's pretty you  have to be pretty smart to dodge that  much taxes and then the second thing he  said and it's not true  [Laughter]